I finally finally watched the Mario
movie oh thank you I thought you're
gonna say something outrageous I was
like I've done that yeah but I watched
it in IMAX 3D how was it it was [__]
awesome why why IMAX 3D because the
option was there at my local Cinema and
I was like well I don't even remember
the last time I watched an IMAX movie
let alone a 3D movie I didn't even know
they were still making 3D movies yeah
what do you mean look because I was just
like ah [__] it no more no because like
3D movies were like kind of like a phase
yeah it was definitely a face everywhere
at one point in a fad and like 3D TVs
and [__] like that well every phase as
well I mean every every movie is like
Sean 3D now yeah oh sorry it is filmed
and they're like oh you can this thing
pops out at one point yeah exactly I've
watched two movies in 3D in the cinema
and both of them start with a
okay
I'm glad you understood that yeah I I
watched it too I liked it uh I really
enjoyed it saying this I just I watched
it and you know sometimes when you watch
a movie and you you pretty much agree
with that everyone already says you're
like like damn I'm not special yeah okay
so what was okay what was the General
consensus with that film because I
didn't get any reviews or anything do
people like it yeah people like it yeah
people like people said that Chris Pratt
was fine yeah Jack Black killed it yeah
[__] he did not need to go that hard as
Bowser I'm sorry you know some people
were just like you know I'm just getting
my paycheck and Jack Black's just like
no I was built for this role actually it
really was a kid yeah
but that's why he's so good it was just
like a tenacious d-roll at one point
that scene where Bowser's just playing
the piano guys
oh my God where did that come do you
think that was actually scripted or did
Jack like the shop in studio one day and
it's like I got a thing I never rejected
Tenacious D song in this film I'd like
to think that they cast him and then
halfway through it they're like hey Jack
and he's like of course
that made me like irrationally happy I
was so happy when that happened yeah I
don't know why it was just so fun yeah
the insane the insane thing is like out
of everyone I think he sounded the least
like himself normally like he's been a
lot of work yeah he put in a lot of work
um oh I forgot his uh name toad uh uh
Michael Key yeah he did not sound like
Michael King no no good good movie I I
almost forgot at one point that that was
Michael Key and I was like oh yeah it
was good why does he sound like that
though yeah I I I will say Seth Rogen
definitely sounded like Seth Rollins
it was an interesting choice yeah I was
like yo Donkey Kong just hit the [__]
blunt man you know thank you
I definitely agree with the take of like
as a movie it's like fine like it's okay
but as like a piece of fan service it's
fantastic oh yeah because Nintendo have
just starved the world of anything
that's not video games for their like
characters yeah or everyone wants to
forget about the 90s live action film
you know yeah like you know the the
closest we got to like decent acting or
anything that was good was like the porn
Mario movie yeah because like I will say
I will say like I came into the Mario
movie with almost zero expectations just
because I didn't I didn't really know
what to expect from a Mario movie do you
know what I mean like how do you make a
plot out of out of Mario like I had no
idea where this could go and I mean this
has been princess gets kidnapped Mario
ghost well it was very like a very
Heroes Journey basic story parents
didn't agree with what he does yeah yeah
yeah you've seen it all before the story
is not special whatsoever it's very
boring yeah but if you like Mario it's
fun
it was just super surreal because I
can't see him I couldn't see a movie
like this existing 20 15 years ago 15 20
years ago because it just the entire
thing just felt like a meme I'm not
gonna lie this this feel like a product
of the internet and I can't put my
finger on why it felt like that but it
it feels like this movie was made for
like meme culture and just for kind of
like internet and maybe Zoomer culture
in general I don't know I imagine that
probably people working on it probably
grew up with that kind of humor and yeah
the games and stuff definitely the part
where I was just like where the [__] did
that come from was the suicidal Luma do
you remember that character oh yeah yeah
I was like where the [__] cause like
there's no because Aki was like so is
there like a character like that in
Mario Galaxy I was like no well not like
that yeah I also realized that if you
don't like care about Mario that much
the movies
the size of Mario scrotum thank you for
that I'd uh yeah I'm gonna continue like
I don't know it was fine I I was happy
yeah I was I was happy I I came in I I
came in not knowing what to expect but
just knowing I would get a bunch of
Mario references and maybe some inside
jokes and that was basically the entire
movie it was the highest budget new
grounds Flash animation I've ever seen
in my life because some of those scenes
where
um you know they just [__] I think
they start playing Beastie Boys or
something at one point and I'm just like
what is this in a Mario movie yeah the
uh the AHA Take On Me segment was a
little bit weird
yeah as like a certified Nintendo kid I
think yeah it was really just like one
huge fan service to like the Nintendo
fan base but like I think they also did
in a really cool way because like there
was just so many [__] Easter eggs in
that film yeah especially like musical
Easter eggs like every time like a new
like Mario would get like a new power up
or like there'd be like a new stage or
whatever they would like do this really
cool thing with I don't know who did the
soundtrack but whoever it wasn't because
like they just so seamlessly
Incorporated little bits and pieces of
like musical Easter eggs into it like
when uh Mario got like the Tanuki suit
and for a split second you can hear the
Mario 3 theme and I'm like that's
[__] cool as like as like as like a
Mario fan yeah I noticed the Luigi
Mansions theme from Young when Luigi was
like by himself or so I was like oh oh
like Rainbow Road as well when it gets
around I run the Rainbow Road theme
starts playing I'm just like that's cool
I was like oh neurons activating oh okay
it almost didn't feel like uh like an
officially licensed thing it very much
felt like if you told me like a fan had
made it yeah you're like yeah because
the whole uh like the one part I did
find kind of weird
um was just the whole Mario Kart segment
I was just kind of like all right
okay
but it kind of just felt like they just
uh were writing the movie as they went
along
like oh we need to put a Donkey Kong
here okay let's uh let's go to uh Donkey
Kong Country okay uh America Let's Do
America uh Rainbow Road oh okay uh and
then they get eaten by a whale
for some reason you should have been the
most one out of ten movie and it
probably still would have popped off
yeah I mean it's fine so that's all
that's our like nine month late
discussion yeah so we all watched it we
all enjoyed it it was good yeah I also
watched I mean I guess we're on movies
um I watched guardians of galaxy three
oh I haven't seen that yet I heard it's
the first good phase Five movie or the
new like posts
yeah phase five of yeah whatever it is a
disease it feels like um that's fine
it's all right
and that's the review thank you very
much for joining in like I I I don't
know I don't know if like learning about
it because I I was not gonna watch it
initially because yeah I just because
like I watched one and two one was very
fun
two I I just found so boring yeah uh I
don't know if you want I've seen the
first two yeah did you like two I
thought it had his moments but at the
same time yeah yeah at the same time I'm
like well one had the magic because he
had this new thing going on he had like
a [__] amazing soundtrack yeah and
two was just like all right we're gonna
do a little more of the same but not too
much different and I'm like okay well
it's good popcorn movie yeah yeah is
Guardians of the Galaxy the one with
Groot yes yes I mean it looks like he
looks like a [__] Roblox character in
this one and I just could not stop
laughing every time I saw him uh yeah it
was fine I mean like it was not the most
compelling movie ever the music was fun
it was great it was long right very long
the villain I thought was [__] stupid
um and he just he only just scream all
the time I don't know I can't believe we
were just talking about two Chris Pratt
movies yeah yeah yeah like I actually
found Chris Pratt pretty likable in this
one
um he's a likable guy in Guardians of
the Galaxy you know that's okay like
what's his name [__] dracthar
whatever where's the killing Guy the one
who shouts oh yeah he's still the
Baptista yeah he's still like the best
guy in that film oh yeah yeah every time
he's on screen I did get a chuckle he
was pretty good that he carried the film
for me um yeah it was fun is it fine
yeah six seven out of ten maybe it's not
like it's like I don't know why people I
think everyone uh I haven't seen it so I
think everyone's just so starved or good
yeah I think she's people have just been
the Marvel fans have just been cucked
yeah like five years now that they're
just like oh something thanks James come
here for the next film right yeah right
my dreams come right we're making
another model film right
um so yeah that was that was nice yeah I
wonder if DC was pissed they were like
why why the [__] did you make a good
film when you're leaving them what the
[__] wrong with you own it in well
isn't he doing a new Flash movie as well
or something
yeah yeah see it where they're like this
because obviously if you don't know
anything about The Flash movie um Ezra
Miller plays The Flash and Miller Miller
is a very uh notorious uh actor and if
you follow any of the kind of a
douchebag yeah
it's an understatement just committed
crime he's like punched people in the
face yeah he's like a [__] up guy I
mean you can on screen now he can get
the list of some things he's a [__]
[__] and um well supposedly uh and uh
there's like articles being like this is
going to redeem Ezra Miller what the
[__] why are we why do we have to redeem
him why can't we just get someone else
who like isn't contentious and all the
critics are like this is this is the
best film ever and it's like I I why
like you could I don't know maybe it's a
piate maybe it's like a big brain Galaxy
brain PR move because no one's gonna
give a [__] about a Flash movie unless
you get some [__] to play yeah maybe